hey guys it's Justine and today I have a
brand new Sony vlogging camera that I
was gonna unbox but I already unboxed it
so
um here it is this is the new zv
vlogging camera Sony has been my go-to
for all of my cameras pretty much
everything that I use in my studio is
all Sony and when I used to do my daily
vlogging I would always Vlog on one of
the little tiny Sony vlogging cameras
this has a one inch sensor and that's
way more than the average smartphone so
obviously if you are comparing phone to
camera you'll be able to get much better
Stills much better low light and with
this Ultra wide lens it's fixed at a 20
millimeter wide angle lens that for me
is the ideal angle for vlogging audio is
also something that is really important
when you're making videos and this has a
built-in directional microphone it also
comes with this windscreen so that'll
help you reduce wind when you're outside
and it even has a mic Jack if you want
to add an external mic it has built-in
image stabilization and the display is
also touch screen so you're able to
operate it directly from the LCD you can
also plug this into your camera to use
it for live streaming or as a webcam
another feature that I love that this
has is background defocus so this lets
you get that beautiful bokeh with just
the Press of a button product showcase
is an awesome setting especially someone
who is always unboxing and showing
products when you turn on this mode
it'll quickly focus on the subject that
you're showing it has face Priority auto
exposure I love this because it'll keep
your subject's face in constant
brightness even if you're recording in
various lighting conditions it has a
self timer countdown for video recording
I love this because sometimes I need to
set myself up get in the shot and make
sure I'm actually in frame it has a
slow-mo function and a hyperlapse
function so this will allow you to shoot
super smooth speeds at 5x slower or up
to 60x faster it also has a soft skin
function so when you turn this on it'll
help adjust your skin smoothness so
here's the camera I kind of just wanted
to give you a quick little overview I
just wanted to show it to you because I
used to be a daily vlogger I would Vlog
my entire life all the time and it was a
lot and now even for me when I travel I
just like taking my phone I don't really
like to bring a lot of other items there
are some advantages that this does give
to you over a phone this is the little
battery which is similar to the RX100 in
some of their previous vlogging cameras
it also has a mic input so you'll be
able to input a 3.5 millimeter
microphone into that it also has HDMI
port another thing that I really like
about this is you can plug this in and
use it as a webcam so if you are a live
streamer or you just want to use this as
a webcam to do conference calls or
classes another thing that I like is
product showcase now let me just give
you a little demo of product showcase so
here it is everything is all turned on
I'm just gonna hit record so we can give
this demo like it'll focus so fast on
the item
oops I like that it has the flip screen
like this so here we go okay hi it's
Justine here I'm talking about this new
camera and I'm going to show you this
item look at that
focus on me focus on item
focus on me focus on item this looks
great I'm so excited about this
so let's see what our Zoom is like let's
do all the way in so this gives us a 1.5
x Zoom
Let's test out the audio so right now
I'm using my love microphone and now
we're going to
switch to the microphone on the camera
and a lot of people sometimes get a
little confused like why does this have
a tuft of hair like this actually it's
so long on this one now here's the audio
on the zv1f what does it sound like I
can just press right here and do Zoom
like you can automatically zoom in like
super fast I like that so I can go
directly from the wide
to the one to the 1.5 it was doing an
eye autofocus but I'm trying to show you
in this top camera okay look look at
that we've got the eye autofocus which
is something that I think is very
important when you're filming I love the
eye autofocus because this makes sure
that your eyes are in focus and I feel
like when you're filming that is
something that you really want to
capture and make sure it's in Focus I
can't stop looking at this because it's
it looks like a person it's also has
some creative looks if you choose to add
those on I usually just do the standard
because I like to add my own looks when
I'm editing in post oh my gosh my
battery's dead I need to charge it
another thing that I really like is you
can actually get an ND filter to put on
top of this lens and if you've never
used an ND filter and you don't know
what that is just picture yourself going
out on a bright day and when you put
sunglasses on everything looks much
clearer you're able to actually see
that's basically what you're doing to
your camera you're putting a little
sunglass on on top of your camera lens
and that gives the camera the ability to
get much clearer crisper images in that
bright harsh light so that's something
that I really love my sister actually
got a demo so she has a video of this on
her channel so I'll put a link in the
description if you want to see hers she
actually shot an episode with this
camera on her Sony show called the
lowdown which is a really fun show her
and Sydney both host it and it's so
awesome so I'm super excited to see that
episode when it comes out I'll put a
link in the description to that show as
well if you want to see it now why I
think this camera is so special is the
fact that it has a 20 millimeter focal
length which is when you're holding this
up that's enough focal length to
actually get yourself in the frame and
that is something that I've always
struggled with because a lot of the
cameras that I have they're usually like
bigger lenses and you are able to
actually get your full face in frame
when I'm watching a video or when I'm
filming like I want to see the full
person in frame so right now I'm
actually heading to San Diego so I'm
going to take this and test it out and
get some shots for you guys so you can
see some of the video quality see some
of the picture quality and I really do
think that this is something that is
super exciting especially for newer
creators if you've never had a camera
before this could be a good first step
into that world
[Music]
do you remember how in my video I said I
was going to San Diego well I went to
San Diego but I didn't film anything and
now I'm in Maryland I don't know I am
so tired right now like I don't know if
you can see it on my face I feel like an
absolute train wreck I took an overnight
flight I was filming all day yesterday
didn't sleep on the overnight flight and
now I'm here with my family so I'm gonna
Vlog a little bit of this trip using the
new Sony Z I keep I'm so sorry Sony like
I keep calling it the wrong thing the
zb1f the thing that I like so much about
it so far is the audio it's very clear I
know I was making fun of the little wind
wig that was on top of it but it's
working quite well I also like this is
the 20 millimeter focal length so I'm
all in the frame like this is the
perfect vlogging frame sometimes a
little bit wider than this is almost too
wide this is pretty much perfect so
let's go enjoy the park show you guys
Bryn it's our niece she has grown up
quite a lot probably since the last time
you've seen her since I don't really
Vlog anymore she is such a little rascal
hey Brian say hi to my camera
hi
you're cute
did you know that
what is it a row
s
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
Cheerios does it look real good you look
like your mom when you do that
that's your mom my face when I said you
look like Mommy no not that one
was another one it was the mad face it
was like that one there that's that's
free that's a brief face that's your
mommy's face there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been having so much fun testing
this out because I'm so used to making
videos with large cameras and they're so
heavy so being able to just have this
it's super light and I just don't even
feel like I'm holding anything basically
feels like I'm holding my phone I'm
getting a b-roll shot here
of what it looks like to hold it I'm
walking so slow that my watch has asked
me if I want to end my workout I don't
[Music]
another cool thing about this camera is
it actually comes in a white version
look at this
it's so
pretty so this is all that Jenna has my
sister actually did a review of this as
well I'll put a link in the description
if you want to check it out but this one
looks so awesome what do you think Bryn
which one do you like better
do you like this black one or do you
like the white one
in the white one oh you like both of
them well you heard it here first she
likes both of them anyway I'm super
excited about this camera and I'm
excited to see what some other fellow
content creators create with it it's a
little windy is there any wind is there
any wind blowing hmm
she's stuck are you stuck
no no Mommy can't come in he can't he's
not out let him out let him out I'm
gonna go back inside it's cold out here
come on go inside it's cold okay well
that's it my video's over uh I'll see
you guys in the next one
I think I might need to give it a little
haircut just like a small trim Maybe
foreign